audi lundi au jeudi jusqu'à 21h30 pour
décrypter les grands thèmes de
l'actualité de la journée au sommaire de
ce jeudi 2 septembre
collectivement on n'a pas été à la
hauteur déclaration d'un emmanuel macron
fraîchement accueillies dans les
quartiers nord de marseille 1 à vue d'un
aveu d'échec de la part du chef de
l'état avant de lancer son grand blanc
pour guérir la ville de ces mots nous
serons sur place et tenteront de
comprendre avec un nos invités pourquoi
la cité phocéenne car une faillite de
l'état
en afghanistan les taliban sont sur le
point d'annoncer la formation de leur
nouveau gouvernement qui ne devrait pas
inclure de femmes du côté du pentagone
c'est l'amertume après ce retrait qui
sonne comme un échec une coopération
avec les talibans pour lutter contre
rodez serait même envisagée nous serons
en direct avec notre correspondant
depuis washington
et puis en français une page de la crise
sanitaire qui se tourne la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte lancé en mars 2020 les
mesures de soutien aux entreprises et
aux salariés devrait s'éteindre à la fin
du mois coût de l'opération quelques 240
milliards d'euros pour l'état avec quels
résultats
peut-on vraiment croire à un arrêt total
de ces aides l'économiste jacques sapir
tentera de répondre à ces questions
et puis à 21h place à notre nouveau
rendez-vous qu'en pensent les français
elle nous sommes allés aujourd'hui à la
rencontre de christian show via qui a
perdu son fils cédric le 3 janvier 2020
après un contrôle de police qui a viré
au drame c'est l'une des effets roble
matic de ceux qui dénoncent des
violences policières grandissante alors
faut-il pointé du doigt la politique
sécuritaire du gouvernement
le divorce entre la police et la
population est il consommé décryptage
avec nos invités
[Musique]
le devoir de la nation est d'être aux
côtés des marseillais et marseillais
c'est sur ces mots qu emmanuel macron a
débuté ce soir son discours interrompu
d'ailleurs quelques instants par un gros
orage dans le ciel phocéen après avoir
abordé les questions de sécurité hier le
chef de l'état a dévoilé son plan pour
la ville aujourd'hui david khalifa vous
êtes en direct sur place que peut-on
retenir de ce discours et de ces
annonces
a bien au final stéphanie peu de
surprises après deux jours de visite
notamment dans un hôpital dans les cités
de 1 des quartiers nord ou bien encore
dans un hôtel de police emmanuel macron
a souhaité montrer qu'il se sentait
concerné par les principaux dossiers de
son grand plan c'est comme ça qu'ils
appellent pour marseille avec un
objectif est clair se donner 15 ans pour
en faire elle a un capital de la
méditerranée alors plusieurs thèmes
abordés lors de ce discours au palais du
pharo les transports l'école l'hôpital
mais évidemment en première ligne c'est
l'insécurité et le trafic de drogue un
cuir et à revenu sur la table le chef de
l'état a détaillé son plan de
financement de 150 millions d'euros pour
les forces de l'ordre où je le rappelle
il s'est engagé à accélérer l'arrivée
des 300 un policier de plus promis par
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin afin que les habitants des
quartiers sensibles puissent revivre
sereinement écoutez
les chiffres sont bons et il s'améliore
mais il ya une criminalité de plus en
plus violente
qui est largement liée au trafic de
drogue et donc c'était une véritable
traque une politique de harcèlement des
trafics
qu'il nous faut conduire 200 policiers
arriveront en 2022 les deux compagnies
de crs supplémentaire présente depuis
mars seront pérennisés financeront le
déploiement de la fibre et 500 caméras
et nous prendrons dans les prochaines
semaines avec nos partenaires européens
des initiatives de coopération pour
démanteler ces réseaux qui sont de plus
en plus présents sur notre sol
pour rappel quinze personnes ont perdu
la vie depuis le début de l'année dans
des règlements de comptes le trafic de
drogue véritable fléau pour la cité
phocéenne pour emmanuel macron les
consommateurs son complice de ces
violences extrêmes à savoir que le chef
d'état a fait savoir qu'il reviendrait
au mois d'octobre et de février à
marseille pour faire le point sur ses
engagements pris et david l'autre
urgence un marseille ce sont évidemment
les logements l'insalubrité notamment
des habitations et des quartiers
difficiles et là aussi david emmanuel
macron a longuement insisté
effectivement une grande partie de son
discours était dédiée à la pauvreté cela
passe par la rénovation des logements
insalubres en rappelant l'engagement un
des dix mille logements réhabilités dans
les 15 prochaines l année un marseillais
sur dix seraient concernés par cette
problématique et je vous propose
d'écouter le président à ce propos qui a
fait encore une fois beaucoup de
promesses
nous nous étions accordés sur un
objectif de réhabilitation et l'a déjà
une fois encore l'état a pris ses
responsabilités en prenant une politique
qui n'est normalement pas la sienne mais
en assumant cet objectif de
réhabilitation de dix mille logements
dans les 15 prochaines années nous
allons continuer de simplifier les
procédures et qu'en particulier la
simplification des recours avec un seul
jugement les chantiers doivent s'engager
immédiatement
je compte sur la mobilisation de tous
les acteurs avaient maintenant désigner
un directeur général les choses sont
construites allons-y et ses paroles elle
symbolise une triste réalité un pour la
ville de marseille c'est pour ça que les
phocéens est concernée ne veulent pas un
simple coup de com à la veille d'une
campagne présidentielle les actes
doivent remplacer les paroles aient les
marseillais n'ont d'ailleurs pas hésité
à lui faire comprendre à travers elle
son parcours dans la ville a à plusieurs
reprises emmanuel macron et s'est fait
huer ou à des slogans ou le envers lui
ont été entendus et le symbole d'un
ras-le-bol général au final pour c'est
un marseillais j'ai pu constater cet
après-midi un ce ras-le-bol constater
cette misère cette pauvreté indécente
c'est comme ça qu'on peut la qualifier
pour la deuxième ville de france en
compagnie de mon caméraman sébastien
dufour nous nous sommes rendus dans le
3e arrondissement de marseille dans la
cité félix et pyatt plus précisément et
le constat est choquant et les
témoignages sont plutôt poignant c'est
un véritable sentiment d'abandon acquis
après domine pour les habitants de cette
cité cité écouter
le problème si les jeunes et les jeunes
ne travaillent pas les jeunes
regardent combien de morts là les
règlements de compte
franchement
y a trop et c'est ça le marché marché
c'est sale c'est ça on est mal à loger
on est mal on est mal
renvoyé et des gens qui hésitent à 10
comme quoi la nouvelle les toilettes et
les salles de bains mais c'est un
travail bidon c'est mal fait on est on
est rien on n'est rien à la vérité est
incroyable c'est un coup de gomme tout
ça c'est du bluff dans deux mois on veut
plus en parler de tout ça moi je pense
que ça sert à rien du tout c'est bien vu
je suis libre un bonjour un peu à droite
à gauche et ça c'est que du cinéma moi
je connais quand pas là c'est bientôt
les élections tout ça il veut se faire
un nom à marseille devait se faire beau
à marseille c'est du bluff tout ça c'est
que du bluff après je sais pas si vous
avez déjà visité les apporter au monde
sait mais ces deux bâtiments délabrés la
plupart ces appartements c'est invivable
je suis dos et les appartements et à des
souris et pourtant il faut bien la
situation est plus que dramatique dans
ces quartiers la plupart des jeunes
qu'on a pu interroger comme vous avez pu
le voir sont assez fataliste ils n'ont
pas le choix pour survivre ils doivent
attirer c'est la triste vérité d'une
ville qui a plus que jamais besoin
d'action et non de promesses merci david
un califat en direct de marseille alors
le plan du président marseille en grand
et il est la hauteur est ce la solution
enfin pour bâtir comme le souhaite
emmanuel macron le marseille de 2030
décryptage à présent avec nos invités
[Musique]
et avec nous ce soir pour en parler
isabelle bonnet porte parole de lutte
ouvrière à marseille bonsoir isabelle
bonnet merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés hacène hamouche président du
collectif marseillais trop jeune pour
mourir bonsoir à seynod merci d'être
avec nous et emmanuel macron qui est
arrivé 1 sous les huées hier on a vu
marseille l'heure ce matin à l'école un
u est également est ce que vous pensez
qu'il a tout de même marqué des points
aujourd'hui aux yeux de la population
avec ses discours et ses annonces
isabelle bonnet
bah écoutez moi j'ai l'impression
d'entendre la même chose qui à cinq ans
pour parrot monte plus en arrière avec
le plan de manuel valls qui était avec
un gros comité interministériel c'était
le même défilé de ministres avaient et
cetera et c'est vrai que c'est du vent
vrai que ce sont tes promesses c'est
vrai ils ce sont des engagements
concrètement la vie dans les quartiers
populaires elle n'a pas changé les
logements sont dégradées de plus en plus
dégradée on a connu depuis le drame de
la rue d'aubagne mais y en a eu un autre
cet été aux flamands avec trois morts à
la suite d'un incendie dans un immeuble
qui était en grande partie soit et c'est
vrai j'ai entendu vos témoignages c'est
vrai que la vie elle devient
insupportable pour les anciens pour les
jeunes compact boulot pour les anciens
qui sont maintenus dans des quartiers où
il n'y a pas de transports pour les
jeunes effectivement qui gagne en une
journée ce que leurs parents peuvent
s'échiner des fois en ménage tôt le
matin a gagné au bout de plusieurs
semaines donc écouter le mal dont on est
en train de crever aujourd'hui c'est le
chômage de masse c'est sûr match de metz
qui ravage les quartiers et là j'ai
absolument rien entendu par rapport à ça
alors il ya quelques annonces on va en
parler dans quelques instants avant cela
vous assène amour
pour vous il a marqué des points ce
président isabelle mon bonnet nous dit
voilà on a entendu ça maintes et maintes
fois ça n'a pas beaucoup impressionné
manifestement vous avez été séduit par
une partie du discours du président et
par ces annonces surtout
au vu de la situation on a envie d'y
croire parce que effectivement et
nouvelle majorité municipale dans la
ville il faut pas oublier il ya un
contexte à marseille de paysans la
république est venu écouter des
habitants qui étaient en grande
inquiétude cette parole là était
finalement la plus marquante de son
déplacement ensuite il annonce une
cinquantaine de médiateurs
supplémentaires et d'éducateurs il
annonce une compagnie de crs pas sûr que
ce soit la bonne solution pour qu'on a
déjà eu l'expérience ou la main sous
l'autorité de nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
ministre d'alors alors qui ça n'a pas
produit ses effets réellement donc
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire tout ce
qui vient d'annoncer ça reste encore au
stade des annonces il ya aussi les
grandes dispositif dont il a évoqué qui
existe déjà dans la ville donc ils
crient rien les annonceurs et les ajuste
il s'en est juste aproprié un certain
nombre de projets et a pris à toutes les
annonces de financement notamment sur la
rénovation des écoles et et de ce fameux
commissariat dont on en avant depuis
quelques mois déjà j'ai l'impression
quand même que l'exercice du président
la république aujourd'hui ilves
totalement le fait que dans huit mois il
ya une élection présidentielle ça veut
dire une arrière pensée
électorale clairement isabelle bonnet il
dit tout de même emmanuel macron
collectivement on n'a pas été à la
hauteur c'est un aveu d'échec tout de
même il ya quelque chose qui va changer
selon vous avec ce président et ses
annonces à on va parler voilà ce carnet
de chèques sortie allègrement
aujourd'hui où comme le dit
votre interlocuteur ce soir finalement
on a un président en campagne électorale
et ça s'arrête là
non mais ça fait plus d'un an et demi
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
que de temps en temps comme ça il fait
un petit acte de mea culpa on n'a pas
fait assez on n'a pas été assez loin on
n'a pas assez at on entendu les gens
dans les quartiers populaires et puis
qu'est ce qui change concrètement
regarder rien par rapport à la situation
catastrophique des hôpitaux puisque les
s'est rendu à l'hôpital de la timone à
marseille cet après midi qu'est ce qui a
changé concrètement combien il ya eu une
embauche en quoi le travail des
soignants et puis de tout le personnel
hospitalier qui est autour des soignants
a été améliorée
cc on est dans la même situation qu'il
ya un an et demi et les soignants épuisé
voir arriver les vagues les unes après
les autres sans que rien ne change si ce
n'est le coup de bâton supplémentaire
avec en plus la culpabilisation avec
l'obligation vaccinale je pourrais vous
parler aussi des écoles puisque je suis
enseignante ça fait combien de temps
qu'on dit que les écoles de marseille
c'est la honte de la république
donc il suffit pas de le dire qu'est ce
qu'on met en avant pour ça change et ben
moi je n'ai rien entendu de ce qui me
semble indispensable pour faire changer
la vie dans ces quartiers créer de
l'emploi massivement par tous recrutés
ces jeunes recrutés pour pouvoir
soulager ceux qui travaillent durement
dans les entreprises et qui n'en peuvent
plus pour pouvoir soulager dans les
transports dans dans dans la santé dans
l'éducation
et puis surtout regarder tous les
emplois qui manquent ne fût-ce que pour
reconstruire toutes ces écoles ne fût ce
que pour reconstruire ces quartiers qui
sont à l'abandon depuis des années comme
la cité qu'il a pu visiter il faut
mettre des moyens massifs mais il faut
surtout embaucher il faut surtout que
les gens disaient du boulot et des
perspectives
cette société se soit pas tu viens de
tels quartiers t'as pas d'issue d'autre
que le trafic de drogue d'autre que de
tomber dans la délinquance ça devient
plus acceptable vous avez de bonnes et
tout de même ce qui met en avant
emmanuel macron voilà c'est plus de 2 1
milliards sur la table des nouveaux euro
des nouveaux chèques on rappelle quand
même hein on va pas tous les rappeler
parce qu'il y en a eu beaucoup d
investissement marseille en 1995 1 06
milliard 1 qui avait été dans des
pensées dans le projet euroméditerranée
françois lamy lui aussi en lors du
dernier mandat de françois hollande
avait investi massivement là encore plus
d'un milliard qui va être investi c'est
vrai qu'à saint amour on se pose la
question vous par exemple sur le terrain
vos associations vous envoyer la couleur
de cet argent parce que c'est autant
d'argent voilà qui creuse la dette est
ce que concrètement on le voit sur le
terrain
nous parlons bien évidemment il ya une
deuxième qui est manque de visibilité
des politiques publiques dans nos
territoires et dans nos cités c'est dans
la vie de tous les jours
quand on voit la mascarade auquel on a
assisté hier d'une cité qui se fait
nettoyés juste avant l'arrivée du
président de la république ce sont des
choses qui ne devraient pas arriver le
président de la république devrait se
rendre compte du quotidien des habitants
dès son arrivée dans les quartiers en
revanche de noircir et pas autant
pardon ni varrault cet argent cet argent
aujourd'hui il ya dix ans il ya
plusieurs il ya plusieurs canaux c'est à
dire qu'à le bâti la rénovation des
écoles primaires si l'engagement a été
pris avec le paysan la république je le
vois pas comment est ce qui pourrait
aujourd'hui faire autrement que
d'essayer de débloquer ces fonds donc je
pense que il tiendra promesse après je
suis pas son porte-parole mais j'espère
qu'il tiendra promesse et après il ya
tout l'investissement dans le vivant et
là je pense que il n'est pas le seul
même si c'en est l'un des acteurs aussi
à devoir m excusez moi l'expression le
paquet sur le vivant et donc les la
présence humaine moyen de service public
dans nos cités il ya le département et à
la métropole et à la vie de la ville
dans une moindre mesure parce qu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui les compétences de la
ville de marseille sont de plus en plus
réduite mais par exemple pour la
fracture des transports qui existe entre
les quartiers nord et le sait et il son
coeur de vie quand on sait que partir du
centre-ville de marseille pour rejoindre
les quartiers nord c'est au bas mot une
heure et demie de transport c'est une
honte donc ces inégalités de destin avec
ces inégalités de territoire avec tout
cela ça forme un cocktail qui est
explosif donc aujourd'hui cet argent là
elle n'arrive pas encore en pied
d'immeuble elle n'arrive pas encore dans
les poches des associations qui
pourraient faire ce travail humain
avec les habitants il ya un manque aussi
je le dis de présence publique et tout
ça malheureusement vous avez raison on
n'en a pas vu la couleur à l'heure où
nous parlons oui parce que cet argent là
je vous parle d'un argent vieux de
quelques dizaines d'années déjà on va on
va regarder ces chiffres assez édifiant
qui résume aussi malheureusement
marseille un pas que mes mais beaucoup
regardé 1,5 milliard d'euros de dettes
deux fois plus élevé que la moyenne des
villes 61 millions d'euros gaspillés
dans la gestion du personnel ça rapport
de la cour des comptes budget 13
millions pour l'investissement les
impôts représentent deux tiers des
recettes 53% de des ménages non
imposables
isabelle bonnet une question peut-être
qu'il va vous paraître un peu naïve est
simple mais pourquoi est ce si compliqué
à marseille finalement
non c'est pas compliqué il suffit en
effet de demander à la population et
c'est très bien les associations comme
celle dans laquelle me dis que ce
monsieur mais y en a des tas
d'associations et puis même dans les
quartiers il ya des ja il ya des gens
qui sont au contact des jeunes de tous
ceux qui sont difficultés il ya eu toute
une scène solidarité pardon qui s'est
mise en place pour pouvoir subvenir au
moment dé confinement successifs y
compris à des problèmes comme simplement
se nourrir au quotidien qu organiser le
ravitaillement qui ont organisé des tas
de choses non ce qui manque c'est la
volonté politique de prendre de l'argent
mais moi quand je vous parle d'argent
comprenez vous parlez d'un milliard rien
ce qui a été donné aux grands groupes au
titre de toutes les aides par l'état ça
se chiffre en centaines de milliards
donc votre milliards c'est une espèce de
d'eau déjà je sais pas dans quelle poche
est trop beau si elle tombe dans la
poche des promoteurs immobiliers qui
construisent du logement cher là où ce
qui manque le plus c'est du logement
dans les quartiers populaires adapté à
des revenus modestes moi ça me fait une
belle jambe 1 qu' il y ait des hôtels
flambant neuf qui est des résidences
luxueuses à marseille parce qu'il ya ça
aussi à marseille non le problème c'est
qu'il faut orienter justement largement
en fonction des besoins de la population
laborieuse en fonction des besoins qui a
dans les quartiers populaires rénover
les écoles c'est une chose si on
n'embauche pas le nombre de tata comme
on dit à marseille c'est à dire d'agents
des écoles pour pouvoir faire
fonctionner les cantines normalement
elles sont un pur 50 enfants dans une
ville comme marseille c'est beaucoup
moins que dans bien d'autres villes de
d'importance moindre
donc voilà elles sont là aussi les
inégalités c'est aussi justement aux
termes d'emploi d'encadrement et ça
honnêtement j'en ai pas entendu un mot
là de la part de toutes les annonces qui
ont été faites j'ai pas entendu ce matin
que blanc caire disait qu'on allait
recruter dans les écoles alors que pas
plus tard qu'il ya deux jours même les
chefs d'établissements étaient devant le
rectorat d'aix-marseille pour dénoncer
le soudoiement de l'académie en termes
de moyens humains donc non temps quand
on met pas sur la table des dizaines de
milliards qu'on a prélevé dans les
dividendes de ces grands groupes
capitalistes qui se gavent ils sortent
encore plus riches de cette crise mois
ce qui m'indigne c'est pour ça que je
suis en colère c'est pas parce que je
noircis les choses parce que moi je me
bats tous les jours pour qu'elle change
les choses mais c'est parce que sam
indigne que les riches soient sortis
encore plus riches de cette crise
sanitaire et les pauvres encore plus
pauvres
donc quand est ce qu'on va inverser ça
il faut qu'on se décide à taper dans la
poche des riches oui pour financer
effectivement tous les besoins utiles à
la population des quartiers populaires
alors asséné mot effectivement sur le
plan de l'emploi
isabelle bonnet on parle depuis le début
effectivement emmanuel macron lui
souhaite mettre en avant je cite un
guichet unique des initiatives dans
bausch de formation des jeunes et de
programme d'alternance 1 je le lis parce
que c'est vrai que c'est assez flou tout
ça pas grand chose
comme mesure sur le trafic de drogue est
ce que
c'est quoi la priorité pour vous plutôt
la lutte contre le trafic de drogue ont
effectivement on contrôle un chômage ou
les deux
mais moi je pense que le plan qui doit
être aujourd'hui développé pour la ville
de marseille c'est doit être un plan
j'ai envie de dire ceux requis ce qui
interviennent sous tous ses aspects de
la vie au quotidien des habitants il ya
la question de la sécurité évidemment il
ya la question des effectifs de police
il ya la question clairement des moyens
des forces de l'ordre là on le voit lui
ce qu'il propose le président de la
république etc sont mises de l'intérieur
c'est donc le renfort des caméras de
surveillance moi je je le dis sur toutes
les mesures qu'il a annoncées
aujourd'hui peu d'entre elles m'ont
convaincu pour une raison simple c'est
qu'on sait très bien que les annonces
des deux cents policiers dont il fait
état il ya une réalité auquel on va être
confronté c augmentent d'effectifs de la
police et comment est ce qu'il va
pouvoir d'une région à l'autre déployé
des unités de police dans la ville de
marseille donc il ya ça mais il faut pas
ici d alors le lutter contre le chômage
des jeunes
investir les quartiers avec des
médiateurs et des éducateurs de rue
toutes ces choses là sont des pour
l'instant au stade des belles paroles à
mettre au compte du président aille plus
vite mais je pense qu'il a bien en
quelques heures cernés quels étaient les
difficultés dans nos quartiers et nous
associatif on a répété donc aux oreilles
des consignes et aux oreilles de
l'entourage du président de la
république et je pense qui s'est aussi
servi nos mots pour raconter la vie dans
son discours présidentiel sauf
qu'aujourd'hui entre je vous le dis
encore une fois même s'il s'est défendu
de vouloir faire la politique
politicienne pendant cette visite il ya
quand même les paroles et des actes et
j'ai l'impression qu'on est plutôt au
stade des paroles et quand on promet
autant d'argent en aussi peu de temps
donc je me demande comment est ce que
réellement tout ça va être mis en oeuvre
et je je je vois que vous avez montré
tout à l'heure un tableau dans votre
émission qui reprenait les finances
l'état des finances de la ville de
marseille c'est vrai cette ville a été
mal gérée pendant des années et ces
années là elle ce sont ceux ce manque de
gestion a eu lieu sous les années godin
il faut aussi le rappeler dans votre
émission bon diagnostic peut-être mais
pas bon remède ski je résume plus ou
moins votre pensée à tous les deux merci
à isabelle bonnet merci également à
scène hamoud avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france injustement notre
reporter david khalifa est allé à la
rencontre d'associations terrain comme
comme la vôtre c'est la boue qui en sont
déjà à pied d'oeuvre pour tenter de
faire changer les choses les images sont
signés sébastien deux fois avec
sébastien azzaba
répondre aux urgences de marseille c'est
l'objectif que s'est fixé l'exécutif
dans le collimateur la délinquance la
violence et la vétusté qui gangrène la
ville et sa jeunesse les acteurs locaux
n'ont pas attendu l'exécutif pour agir
l'association familles en action ses
forces depuis sept ans de sortir des
jeunes des quartiers difficiles afin de
leur offrir de vraies perspectives
d'avenir certains ont déjà des plans de
carrière
moi mon groupe c'est dejiang footballeur
c'est ça depuis tout petit c'est ça
d'être entrepreneur dieu entreprises
pour créer par exemple propre marque
pour voir si ça peut rapporter ou même
réussir et devait devenir quelqu'un
mohamedou sam et éducateur lui même a
rejoint l'association à l'âge de 14 ans
aujourd'hui il coordonne les
opportunités pour ces jeunes on essaie
peut-être de développer des partenariats
et de visiter par dans des clubs comme
par exemple et on a ramené trois jeunes
à l'entraînement c'est pour essayer de
redonner des des choses pour réussir
parce en plus peut-être qu'il y en a
certains ils peuvent pas se déplacer
jusqu'à là bas tout ça
possible
c'est dans les locaux de l'association
que les liens se créent ici les jeunes
passent leur permis une du rattrapage
scolaire mais avec une si petite
structure seuls quelques dizaines
d'adolescents peuvent bénéficier de
cette aide mohamed attendent beaucoup
des manuels macron
des choses concrètes pour les jeunes et
nous c'est ça en fait parce qu'il ya
deux ans j'étais jeune on va dire je
croyais à à ce qu'elle a à dire l'avenir
qui il a dit qu'il allait nous verrons
visiter tout ça et on attend ça on
attend de voir et on veut qu'ils voilà
la réalité du secteur on les voit pas
forcément les élus on les voit que que
les pendant les élections pendant des
choses comme ça quand ils ont besoin de
nous mais après nous on a l'impression
que quand on a besoin d'eux ils sont pas
une lueur d'espoir peut-être pour la
jeunesse emmanuel macron a promis un
plan de plus d'un milliard d'euros pour
la rénovation de plus de 200 écoles
marseillaise reste à savoir à quelques
mois de la présidentielle
s'il ne s'agit pas là d'une énième
promesse électorale
douze millions d'élèves ont repris le
chemin des classes ce matin une nouvelle
fois dans un contexte de crise sanitaire
le gouvernement a choisi le protocole
dit de niveau 2 en france métropolitaine
similaire à celui de juin dernier
nouveauté cette année des purificateurs
d'air et des détecteurs de co2 dans
certains établissements écoutez
pas tout à fait normalement avec les
masques etc ça gêne un petit peu quand
même la relation mais oui c'est une
rentrée qui est presque normal et c'est
mieux pour les enfants c'est mieux pour
un peu pour tout le monde que ont
finalement on s'habitue à vivre avec
malheureusement ce n'est pas notre
première rentrée avec le protocole
sanitaire donc on a déjà une certaine
expérience
donc on essaie d'accueillir correctement
nos élèves en essayant de mettre en
avant quand même la scolarité et le
bien-être à l'école et puis évidemment
sans omettre toutes les règles
sanitaires que nous avons déjà mises en
oeuvre l'année dernière et pour lesquels
nous sommes quand même d'ores et déjà
bien rodé donc malheureusement on aurait
bien aimé faire une rentrée plus
ordinaire bon ce n'est pas encore
possible mais en tous les cas on a une
expérience à faire valoir et en ces
temps de rentrée c'est une page de la
crise sanitaire qui va bientôt se
tourner la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
lancé en mars 2020 à la fin du mois donc
ces aides auront dans leur ensemble
écouter quelques 240 milliards d'euros
au budget d'état mais avec quels
résultats peut-on vraiment croire un
arrêt total de ces aides dont elles se
poursuivent d'une façon ou d'une autre
on voit se met tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir c'est notre
rubrique l'édito échos
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques sapir merci d'être chair
et en os sur le plateau je suis ravi de
vous y accueillir alors évidemment la
question que l'on se pose aujourd'hui
qu'on craint d'ailleurs est ce que
l'état va cesser ces aides avec un
retour à la quasi normale qui se profile
jacquin oui alors effectivement on
s'attendait même certains le redoutent
et on s'attendait justement à ce que ce
soit la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte alors
il faut toujours rappeler que ce quoi
qu'il en coûte il a coûté rien que pour
le soutien à l'économie
240 milliards d'euros c'est ce qu'a dit
olivier dussopt tu le ministre du budget
est globalement évidemment si on prend
l'ensemble des sommes qui ont été
déboursés sur 2020 sur 2021 et qui le
seront encore 2022 on attend 4 124
milliards d'euros ça fait beaucoup donc
est-ce que le gouvernement va pouvoir
arrêter le robinet comme cela d'un coup
ou bien est-ce qu'il sera contraint
d'une certaine manière de continuer d
aide c'est aussi une question qu'il faut
poser et j'avoue que on peut quand même
douté d'un arrêt immédiat du quoi qu'il
en coûte alors reprenons un petit peu
les choses par le début d'où vient ce
crois qu'il en coûtait et quel bilan
peut-on en tirer bien emmanuel macron a
dit évidemment le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est pour sauver l'économie il l'a
répété plusieurs fois ne serait ce que
dans son allocution du 12 juillet
dernier bon il faut savoir qu'à partir
du moment où l'état imposé à certains
entreprises de manière administrative de
fermer du fait de la pandémie et des
fallait compenser le manque à gagner
donc d'une certaine manière oui ce pas
qu'il en coûte ils étaient obligés après
c'est vrai que l'état fait beaucoup il a
fait beaucoup mais est on le voit sur le
graphique 1 pas nécessairement plus que
d'autres pays la france se situe à peu
près au milieu et puis il faut quand
même dire une chose c'est que ce quoi
qu'il en coûte il a été distribué de
manière assez inégal alors dans quelle
mesure les salariés ont-ils justement
profiter de ces aides vous avez tout à
fait raison stéphanie les salariés ont
été parmi les principaux bénéficiaires
vous savez que dans le quoi qu'il en
coûte 50 % des salariés ont été aidées
vient en particulier le chômage partiel
c'est un chiffre qu'il faut comparer 22%
seulement en italie 20 % en allemagne 11
% en espagne après et bien quand on
regarde le cas des travailleurs
indépendants une autre partie importante
quand même de la population qui
travaille et bien c'est pas du tout
aussi glorieux en ce qui concerne les
travailleurs indépendants on est qu'au
12e rang au niveau européen donc ça
prouve bien que dans ce quoi qu'il en
coûte certains en ont profité et c'est
très bien mais d'autres ont été plutôt
laissé de côté et donc ça plutôt aggravé
les inégalités de ce point de vue là
alors jacques de nouvelle z à la carte a
priori devrait prendre le relais mais
comment ça va se passer concrètement
c'est effectivement la grande question
le gouvernement a décidé d'arrêter les
aides forfaitaires donc de mettre fin au
fond de
vos fonds de solidarité le 30 septembre
et il voudrait passer à des aides qui
serait plus ciblée alors à la fois sur
des secteurs qui ont plus souffert comme
par exemple le secteur de l'événementiel
le secteur du tourisme d'affaires
et ils voudraient aussi le recentrer sur
les entreprises qui ont besoin après ça
va quand même posé un problème de calcul
alors on peut donc penser un sauf erreur
de ma part que les elles ne s'arrêteront
pas c'est bien cela va votre idée oui
parce que si vous voulez
fondamentalement d'une part il y a le
problème des prêts garantis par l'ip
alors ces prêts garantis par l'état
important 160 milliards en un an et demi
mais ces prêts garantis par l'état il
faut les rembourser ce sont des prêts de
même qui va falloir rembourser
les la dette sociale la dette fiscale là
on parle de report sur 2022 sur 2023
mais ça veut dire qu'il y aura toute une
somme importante qu'il va falloir
rembourser et qui peut poser problème à
des petites et des moyennes entreprises
et puis d'un autre côté on a des
secteurs qu'il va falloir continuer à
aider bien sûr qu'il ya des secteurs qui
ont profité de cette crise vous savez le
e-commerce il se réjouit plutôt de la
crise sanitaire mais il ya d'autres
secteurs qui ont été très durement
touchée et donc si on combine ce qu'il
va falloir donner aux entreprises
pour qu'elles puissent rembourser il va
falloir que l'état en fait tu payes ce
remboursement d'une certaine manière est
ce qu'il va falloir donner au secteur
qui ont beaucoup souffert et qui n'ont
pas encore et qui sont loin d'avoir
retrouvé même le chiffre d'affaires de
2019 eh bien ça va faire une certaine
somme alors en conclusion raid pensez
vous que sont d'autres femmes le
quoiqu'il en tout 25 août va finalement
perdurer oui on peut le penser pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord il ya un fait
qui est évident nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans une année préélectorale
si vous voulez on voit bien que le
gouvernement va faire toutes les
dépenses qu'ils estiment nécessaires à
la réélection des manuels macron donc ça
c'est une première chose ensuite il ya
une autre question qui est évidente
c'est justement le fait que si on arrête
ces aides de manière nette on risque de
condamner à mort un nombre important
d'entreprises
le bureau d'études altares estime à 60
milles les petites et moyennes
entreprises qui sont dans une situation
de tension financière extrêmement
importante donc ça veut dire que ce mur
des faillites que l'on n'a pas vu pour
l'instant eh bien on pourrait peut-être
le voir en 2022 ça ferait quand même
très mauvais effet en année électorale
d'avoir une vague de faillites et puis
il y a les aides que le gouvernement
veut mettre en place et là c'est
clairement dans une logique
préélectorale le rsa jeunes dont on
parle beaucoup
la suppression des impôts de production
c'est une bonne chose mais ça représente
de toutes les manières une nouvelle aide
pour les entreprises et donc si on
combine tout cela bien on peut penser
que le quoi qu'il en coûte n'est pas
tout à fait prêt à s'arrêter on voit ça
voici un dossier qu'on va pouvoir suivre
dans les mois qui viennent sera
réellement fixé à verser vos prévisions
étaient les bonnes merci j'ai accepté
d'avoir été avec nous en direct donc sur
ce plateau
l'actualité internationale
à présent en afghanistan les taliban
sont sur le point d'annoncer la
formation de leur nouveau gouvernement
qui ne devrait pas évidemment comme on
se l'imaginé inclure deux femmes ils
reprennent actuellement possession de
l'aéroport saccagé de la capitale
l'armée américaine abandonner beaucoup
de matériels militaires détruits sur
place reportage de mourad gdf envoyée
spéciale à kaboul
cet endroit a l'air bien différent de
celui où nous sommes arrivés pendant
l'évacuation il le nettoie il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire avec tous
les véhicules tout l'armement toutes les
munitions qui ont été abandonnés par les
forces américaines et leurs alliés lors
de leur retraite quant au fils barbelés
il y en avait plusieurs murs parfois
aussi aucune personne c'est toujours en
cours de démantèlement mais comme je les
dis
il y encore beaucoup de travail cette
évacuation que le pentagone a qualifié
de la plus grande et la plus complexe de
l'histoire a laissé derrière elle un tas
de déchets d'épaves et de débris nous
dit ce lieutenant des talibans ils ont
détruit 95% de l'équipement du matériel
et des systèmes ils ont tout détruit les
véhicules les avions sur tous les avions
militaires qui ont été quant à eux
détruit à 100% nous avons demandé à voir
l'aéroport et après être monté dans une
camionnette notre voeu a été exaucé
c'était comme un plateau de cinéma pour
une scène apocalyptique
notre premier arrêt fût le cimetière
d'hélicoptères dont les hélicoptères et
il y en a beaucoup abandonnée dans
l'aéroport de kaboul ont été sabotés
assez visiblement les câbles ont été
coupés les différents blocs électriques
retirer et écraser apparemment avec une
masse tout ce que les talibans même les
afghans pouvait utiliser les américains
l'ont détruit et ce qu'ils n'ont pas pu
détruire ils l'ont laissé tomber
voici des caches pour chiens qui ont
provoqué une grande polémique en ligne
nous avons appris que oui beaucoup de
chiens ont été abandonnés par les
militaires américains mais ils ne sont
pas restés enfermés dans les cages comme
on nous l'avait fait croire ils ont été
relâchés semble-t-il avant le départ
définitif des troupes américaines
quelqu'un a ouvert toutes ses cages et
leur a laissé de la nourriture sur
internet les défenseurs des animaux se
sont mobilisés par milliers il
s'indignait que les troupes américaines
aient pu abandonner ses chiens juste là
à côté des pistes à la merci des
talibans
les américains ont laissé sortir les
chiens
mais nos équipes et nos représentants
officiels s'en occupe désormais
il essaie de les rassembler et de créer
toutes les conditions nécessaires à
leurs besoins
qu'ils soient en sécurité
c'est peut-être exactement ce dont les
taliban ont besoin une bonne campagne
médiatique rassembler les chiens les
remettre aux activistes et récolter les
lauriers humanitaire d'un autre côté ils
ont déjà beaucoup de pain sur la planche
les américains ne se sont pas contentés
de détruire les véhicules ils ont
saccagé bien plus que cela
quand je suis arrivée à l'aéroport dans
la matinée j ai vu beaucoup de
destructions
beaucoup de choses ont été saccagés je
ne sais pas qui a fait ça mais dans les
faits les américains étaient là le
département des ressources en eau que
vous voyez derrière moi a été endommagé
mais par la grâce d'allah nous avons
réussi nous l'avons réparer
une autre chose intéressante dans
l'aéroport ce sont les centaines de
véhicules diplomatiques blindés
abandonnés au cours de l'évacuation ils
ont utilisé ces mêmes véhicules pour
bloquer les routes pendant l'évacuation
voici le contrôle des passeports à
l'aéroport international de kaboul
le voici tel qu'il a été abandonné une
fois l'évacuation terminé pour une
raison indéterminée outre la destruction
de tous les véhicules et avions
militaires que les états unis ont
abandonné ils ont également anéanti une
grande partie de l'infrastructure civile
de l'aéroport ordinateur scanner
corporel caméra et même les écrans
d'arrivée et de départ ici dit on les
américains ont coupé les câbles
électriques renversé des écrans brisé
les fenêtres enfoncer les portes et même
piller les distributeurs automatiques
pourquoi c'était peut-être l'ennui
peut-être la haine on ne sort pas d'une
guerre de 20 ans qui se conclut par une
évacuation humiliante son ressentir un
peu de rancoeur et de son côté le
pentagone nuit est abasourdi par ce
retrait chaotique d'afghanistan il
promet de s'engager à tirer les leçons
de ces vingt années de guerre on
retrouve notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet bonsoir thomas
pour la première fois donc depuis la fin
de l'évacuation un aéroport de kaboul
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi les deux
principaux responsables du pentagone ont
pris la parole une conférence de presse
attendu que vous avez suivi thomas que
peut-on retenir des déclarations des
autorités militaires américaines
et bien une fois n'est pas coutume on
est sorti quelque peu des discours très
factuelle de la part de ses deux
représentants du pentagone qui ont
eux-mêmes combattu en afghanistan au
cours de leur carrière ils nous ont un
peu dé livrer leurs sentiments je sais
que c'est l'un des jours ont été
difficiles pour beaucoup d'entre nous a
par exemple déclaré lloyd austin le
secrétaire américain à la défense et
puis marc mulet le chef d'état-major à
lui parler de la douleur et de la colère
qu'il pouvait ressentir après avoir
constaté le résultat de ces 20 années de
guerre menée par les etats-unis en
afghanistan avec également une pensée
pour ces hommes qui sont tombés au
combat lors de cette guerre mais en tant
que soldat professionnel dit il il doit
contenir sa douleur et sa colère pour
exécuter sa mission jusqu'au bout il
s'agissait donc la première prise de
parole officielle des représentants du
pentagone depuis la fin de l'opération
d'évacuation quelque peu chaotique qui
s'est déroulée jusqu'à la nuit de lundi
à mardi dernier 124 mille civils ont été
évacuées une opération qui a donc été
saluée par lloyd austin je propose de
l'écouter
nous venons de terminer la plus grande
opération d'évacuation aérienne deux
civils de l'histoire américaine c'était
héroïque c'était historique
et j'espère que tous les américains
s'uniront pour remercier nos militaires
pour leur courage et leur compassion
on appelle à l'unité qui intervient
alors que les critiques pleuvent en
contre le pentagone et sa gestion
controversée de ce retrait d'afghanistan
oui le retrait très souvent présenté
comme un fiasco et les images de ces
dernières semaines ont beaucoup marqué
l'opinion alors derrière ce qui est
présenté comme un succès opérationnel et
logistique le pentagone aussi reconnaît
des erreurs aucune opération n'est
jamais parfaite a par exemple déclaré
lloyd austin qui a appelé à tirer toutes
les leçons possibles concernant ces
vingt années de guerre menée par les
etats-unis en afghanistan et puis ces
derniers jours des associations de
vétérans qui ont combattu en afghanistan
exprimé aussi de vives critiques à
l'encontre du secrétaire d'état
américain à la défense et du chef d'état
major qui auraient dû selon eux
dissuader joe biden de procéder à ce
retrait si soudain à des troupes
américaines en afghanistan certains ont
même appelé à la démission des deux
hommes écoutez la réponse de l'un des
intéressés lloyd austin en l'occurrence
mais nous ne devrions pas nous attendre
à ce que les anciens combattants
d'afghanistan soit plus indulgents que
tout autre groupe d'américains
j'ai entendu des opinions différentes de
chaque côté ces derniers jours et c'est
vital
c'est la démocratie
c'est l'amérique
et nul doute que les critiques vont se
poursuivre à mesure que la situation
continue d'évoluer en afghanistan suite
au retrait des troupes américaines
d'ailleurs le destine se rendra la
semaine prochaine dans le golfe pour
suivre les procédures d'évacuation
menées par les pays conjointement avec
les états unis dans la région merci
thomas bonnet en direct de washington
et pour approfondir le sujet nous sommes
à présent avec david rigaud l'hérault
rédacteur en chef de la revue orient
stratégique chercheur associé à l'iris
bonsoir david au niveau des roses merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france ce soir les talibans donc un
qui doit annoncer une manière imminente
leur futur gouvernement dès ce soir ils
ont annoncé on ironise un peu sur relay
la surprise qu'aucune femme nora de de
hautes responsabilités
à quoi doit-on s'attendre à partir du
moment où il était très compliqué
d'identifier un d'aider les responsables
vraiment c'est les talibans et qu'on
sait qu'il ya plusieurs branches
chez eux
oui oui le voile n'est pas encore levé
et effectivement il ya sûrement des
tensions importantes dans la mouvance
talibane parce qu'il ya une ligne plus
politique on va dire plus policier
incarné par mollah baradar qu'à négocier
que les américains aient ainsi que par
stanikzaï keita d'oise le même qui a dit
d'ailleurs qu'il réprouve et rend pas
féministe et puis il ya des durs qui
sont proches de du réseau haqqani
notamment et des chefs militaires donc
les tensions sont perceptibles dans la
composition d'un gouvernement qui
officiellement se voudrait inclusif avec
toutes les réserves que ce terme impose
compte tenu des circonstances
parce que effectivement la question est
de savoir inclusives comment pour qui
par rapport à l'ensemble des forces
politiques des ethnies afghanes donc
tout l'enjeu est là dessus parce que
c'est aussi une condition sinequanone
pour une éventuelle reconnaissance à
l'international mais juste avant
j'allais venir fait la transition
l'enjeu pour eux c'est évidemment aussi
d'être des interlocuteurs crédibles pour
le plus de pays possible on imagine
oui parce qu'il ya le se profile une
crise économique et même on va dire
alimentaire
à l'automne il ya les talibans n'ont pas
d'argent ils ont beaucoup de compétences
humaines sont sortis effectivement dans
le flux aérien qui a été mis en place
dans les américains donc la question
celle équilibre qui va être qui va être
cherchée par parler aux talibans en
quelque sorte il ça pourrait être un mix
assez paradoxal d'ailleurs entre le
modèle iranien et et le système tribal
saoudien toutes choses égales par
ailleurs parce que le habib habibou a
batu là à caussade à serait qui est
l'amiral mouminine commandeur des
croyants pourrait renvoyer à la figure
tutélaire du guide suprême en iran mais
en même temps il s'agit aussi de prendre
en compte les réalités et nico
confessionnelle de l'afghanistan dont
pour l'instant il ya un grand point
d'interrogation bcc ce serait quelque
chose d'assez inédit effectivement le
général mac mis les uns déclaré qu'une
une coopération entre l'armée américaine
et les talibans pour combattre bêche cas
donc l'état islamique au corazon serait
donc possible vous vous y croyez vous
c'est un petit peu scénique
effectivement comme comme démarche
les contacts ont été non publique
évidemment mais très étroit au moment de
l'opération d'évacuation aériennes
notamment pour prévenir des attentats on
se dit qu'effectivement il ya eu des
transmissions d'informations des deux
côtés un pur qui ont permis d'aller ans
qui aurait permis d'éviter plus
d'attentats que ceux qui se sont déjà
produits hélas donc il ya de fait un
principe de réalité qui s'impose aux
deux parties et on peut pas exclure que
ça un lien soit maintenue
par la suite parce qu'effectivement la
question problématique de l'état
islamique est un enjeu majeur pour la
communauté internationale et pour le
nouveau régime qui veut ça c'est qu'il
veut s'installer en afghanistan
effectivement ces mêmes chefs
d'états-majors 1 qui déclare que les
responsables du pentagone s'engagerait à
tirer les leçons tactique opérationnel
et stratégique de ses 20 ans de conflit
c'est un aveu cheikh a de mieux cacher
oui mais ça ça fait partie j'allais le
dire c'est le texte retour sur
expérience qui va prendre du temps parce
que de toute façon il y avait eu des
hypothèques qui était très lo depuis
longtemps elles ont été soldés
brutalement par le président joe biden
alors on peut critiquer effectivement la
manière dont ça s'est fait sur le fond
je pense pas qu'ils aient de la part de
l'opinion américaine un rejet de la
décision qui a été prise c'est plutôt
sur les modalités de effectivement le
pentagone de ce point de vue là à
considérer non sans raison que les
choses auraient sans doute pu être
différente fait différemment et de
manière moins
moir moins compliquée qu'elle m'en étais
mais sur le fond de toute façon ça
engage un retrait américain
qui considère que ces ressources ne
peuvent pas être dilapidés sur une
multiplicité théâtre il s'agit de
recentrer les intérêts sur les intérêts
nationaux américains par rapport aux
défis qui est le défi majeur d'ailleurs
qui est par rapport à la chine et la
indirectement l'afghanistan pourrait
redevenir une carte parce que le retrait
américain ne fait pas forcément les
affaires de tous les pays limitrophes
oui sauf qu'entre temps tout de même
washington aurait dépensé 2260 milliards
de dollars dont 83 milliards dans la
formation de la vigne et à lèvres mais
afghane tout ça pour ça sans compter
évidemment les morts 2004 156 soldats
tués américain 47 mille afghans tout ça
pour retourner à la à la case départ et
on nous dit finalement que l'opinion
américaine n'en tient pas rigueur à
l'administration
oui à la case départ on peut pas
considérer que ici rien passé les
talibans eux mêmes d'ailleurs prennent
conscience parce qu'il se heurte à une
réalité sociologique nouvelles qui ne
sont probablement sous-estimé une
réalité sociologique urbaine notamment
parce que il ya eu 20 ans d'accès à une
forte d'éducation aux réseaux sociaux et
donc on n'est plus dans on n'est plus
dans la situation de 2001 les américains
s'en sont rendu compte par
par la gestion effectivement calamiteuse
des événements mais les talibans aussi
et la prise en charge de ce pays ne va
pas être simple du tout pour eux et ça
explique d'ailleurs les hésitations qui
est actuel pour la composition d'un
gouvernement parce qu'ils savent que le
défi va être considérable pour eux
dernière question jean yves le drian
d'oran dans le figaro a misé des
affaires étrangères nabil afghanistan
mais n'est pas synonyme de déclin
américain vous vous partagez cette cette
analyse
oui ça fait référence bon effectivement
là au déclin qui avait été annoncé après
la chute de saïgon en 1975 et puis qui a
donné lieu à une résurgence de ils
n'affirment as une réaffirmation la
puissance américaine sous la présidence
reagan
déclare relative parce que les
américains on sent obligé de se
reconstruire à l'intérieur d'eux ils ne
peuvent pas dilapider les ressources que
je disais tout à l'heure et est donc ils
ont décidé de les expéditions
missionnaire c'est c'est une époque
révolue de de prendre en charge le défi
stratégique en fait qui est défi chinois
et qui va mobiliser toutes leurs
ressources autant politique
qu'économique
merci beaucoup david rigaud les roses
nous avoir apporté votre analyse merci à
vous d'avoir été en direct sur rt france
est une zone rebelle uns résistent
toujours celle de la vallée du panchir
des combattants issus de ministres
anti-talibans et d'anciens membres des
forces de sécurité afghanes place
maintenant aux négociations maxine abers
résister encore et toujours dans la
vallée du panchir ils sont les seuls à
encore tenir tête aux talibans nous
faisions partie des anciens moudjahidine
nous avons appris que les talibans
veulent se diriger vers la vallée du
panchir nous sommes prêts à la défendre
jusqu'à notre dernier souffle nous
défendrons notre patrie notre honneur
national et tout l'afghanistan
nous avons pris les armes pour notre
honneur pour l'islam ces talibans sont
des étrangers nous sommes ici pour notre
honneur et pour notre patrie nous
défendrons notre patrie pas seulement la
vallée du panjshir
nous défendrons tout l'afghanistan nous
sommes prêts en cas de guerre à défendre
chaque coin chaque personne en
afghanistan chaque région de
l'afghanistan
historiquement cette vallée située au
nord de kaboul étroite et difficile
d'accès est un des bastions de
résistance
russe britannique est taliban des années
90 s'y sont cassé les dents
lundi les nouveaux maîtres de kaboul ont
bien tenté une offensive mais au moins
sept d'entre eux ont trouvé la mort dans
les combats désormais il appelle à la
négociation
un appel entendu par les habitants de la
vallée à condition que le mouvement
islamique dépose lui aussi les arts
notre message aux talibans et que nous
voulons la paix nous devons être en paix
les uns avec les autres le monde entier
sait que même lors de la première
résistance ils sont venus avec la force
la force n'a pas fonctionné et ils ont
dû partir notre message est que nous
devons faire la paix le peuple du
panchir accueillera toujours la paix
s'ils n'acceptent pas la paix et
viennent par la force alors le champ de
bataille est prêt pour eux
devrions-nous nous réconcilier avec les
talibans il devrait déposer leurs armes
la guerre l'occupation la force n'ont
jamais été une solution pour ce pays et
ne le seront jamais s'ils veulent entrer
dans le panchir par la force ils
emporteront ce rêve dans leur tombe
ahmad masood fils du célèbre commandant
massoud tué la veille des attentats du
11 septembre 2001 et dont le portrait
trône toujours sur les portes de la
vallée ya rassemblé quelques 9000 hommes
armés composés de locaux d'afghans fuite
ou d'anciens membres des forces de
sécurité
l'ancien vice-président amrullah saleh
s'y est lui aussi réfugié s'il reste en
contact avec les milices talibanes en
vue de négociations le front national de
résistance se disait prête à un conflit
de longue durée sans moyens militaires
ni armée entraînée avec la seule
géographie comme allié
reste à savoir combien de temps
pourront-ils résister au siège et peser
sur les évènements qui secoue la région
et le pays
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
notre rubrique on pense les français
notre journaliste neige abderrazak est
allé à la rencontre de christian
souvient le père de cédric décédé le 8
janvier 2020 après un contrôle de police
et puis nous débattrons à la suite de la
diffusion ce reportage avec nos invités
de la violence grandissante dans la
société sous le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macro
[Musique]
est-ce qu'à une période de stabilité en
haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que ça
existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président à un public averti l'état
de droit a été véritablement mis à mal
pour permettre l'assassinât sur un mode
crapuleux l'on a vu en fait se
constituer des armées privées qui
aujourd'hui ont totalement perdu le
contrôle de leur trou et lorsque ces
gangsters sont recrutés par des hommes
politiques ça vous donne une situation
pratiquement de guerre civile nous
sommes ici au coeur d'un système
extrêmement un briquet d'intérêt à la
fois intérieure et extérieure de toute
façon
mafieux cela ne peut que contribuer à la
dé construction d'un état moderne et
démocratique
[Musique]
la fed pourrait bien fermer le robinet
la majorité de ses membres se disent
favorables au top twin une réduction des
achats d'actifs aujourd'hui on est dans
quelque chose qui ne peut pas être
modifiée vous êtes obligés d'en remettre
à chaque fois un petit peu plus
l'économie réelle est le suis pas donc
c'est le moment de communiquer rosso
modo de faire comprendre à tout le monde
dont cette politique elle pose des
problèmes on est en train de mettre
l'économie réelle à risque on la soumet
vraiment un risque important
les banques centrales aujourd'hui son
market dépendantes et uniquement martel
dépend donc si elles ne veulent pas
aujourd'hui réduire leurs achats c'est
tout simplement parce que elles savent
très bien que le jour où elle annonce
seront réellement une réduction de leurs
achats les marchés vont s'effondrer
mais je le dette on parle de 150 mille
enfants dont caméra d'un métis et inuits
qui ont été envoyés dans ces pensionnats
comment ça s'est passé le début de cette
politique
coloniale a été de devenir un territoire
et 38 enfants sans le consentement des
parents et les arachides leur pays toit
pour les amis dans d'autres régions dans
deux provinces très très loin l'objectif
était de tuer l'envié dans la fin jean
justement 182 tombes anonymes ont été à
découverte sur le site d'un ancien
pensionnat à cranbrook en colombie
britannique
et c'est la troisième découverte de ce
type en un mois on parle ici de génocide
de politique génocidaire sa voix au delà
de la culture mais plutôt un crime
contre
l'humanité au sein d'une nation
et puis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions ou du
symbolisme en termes de technique ce
sera absolument parfait et ils veulent
une fanfare d'un possible pour la coupe
du monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le faut ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent tu sais
c'est que dalle en fait ces pilotes donc
si vous voulez aujourd'hui être affiché
à travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde et ses rêvés pour le qatar
qu'est-ce qu'on va reparler d'eux est en
forme pour des raisons de manière plutôt
mélioratif plutôt faible
[Musique]
et
en suisse un fonctionnement politique
très particulier
elle permet à ses citoyens de se
prononcer sur les lois temps proposé et
même de les faire retirer éventuellement
en suisse il ya nos outils le premier
qui permet d'attaquer des lois l'autre
instrument c'est l'initiative populaire
qui permet d'être duire un nouvel
article de la constitution le fit même
que un sujet aride votation signifie
qu'il ya un problème ce qui oblige les
les partenaires comme dit qu'à se
remettre autour de la table mais stérile
pourrait pas y avoir de dérive populiste
vu leurs proches de risque doit d'avoir
des votations sur des sujets dits
populiste
mais je pense malgré tout que le
meilleur moyen pour lutter contre le
populisme c'est précisément pour
discuter et de trancher
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france concède deuxième
partie d'émission
place à notre nouveau au rendez vous
dans quelques instants qu'on pense les
français nous sommes allés ce soir la
rencontre de christian show via qui a
perdu son fils cédric le 3 janvier 2020
après un contrôle de police qui a viré
au drame c'est l'une des affaires
emblématiques de ceux qui dénoncent des
violences policières grandissante dans
le pays alors faut-il pointé du doigt la
politique sécuritaire du gouvernement le
divorce entre la police et la population
at il été consommés décryptage avec nos
invités
[Musique]
les affaires de violences policières
présumées se multiplient et se
ressembler à huit mois de la
présidentielle
le sujet pourrait bien embarrasser un
emmanuel macron candidat à sa propre
réélection
alors que le sujet sécuritaire sera l'un
des enjeux campagne de 2022 farah mais
qui
[Applaudissements]
dès qu'il ya une bavure il doit y avoir
une réponse et une sanction c'est en ces
termes qu'en 2017 le candidat emmanuel
macron décrivez la politique à appliquer
contre les violences policières à
quelques mois de la fin de son
quinquennat
cette promesse est loin d'être tenu en
france en fait il n'y a eu aucune action
qui a été prise malgré le fait que ces
pratiques sont documentés connus
reconnus dénoncé le président de la
république a reconnu
dix ans de contrôles discriminatoires en
décembre 2020 mais le gouvernement a
toujours failli à 100 à son obligation
d'agir pour faire disparaître ce grave
manquement les contrôles
discriminatoires ne sont pas les seuls
vecteurs de violences policières outre
les polémiques du aux affaires zyed et
bouna adama traoré ou encore michel est
claire la question d' abus de force par
les autorités devient un sujet de débat
national notamment suite aux premières
manifestations de gilet jaune pendant
lesquelles des dizaines de manifestants
ce sont éborgné ou gravement blessés les
images de violences font le tour du
monde amnesty international l'onu et la
haut commissaire aux droits de l'homme
du conseil de l'europe pointe du doigt à
l'usagé excessif de la force contre les
manifestants toujours le même leitmotiv
1 contre les violences policières et
surtout pour avoir une justice rappelle
qu'on est deux fois victime une fois
qu'on prend un coup sur la gueule de la
part d'un cup et qui ont pu y a pas de
justice derrière autre problème à gérer
place beauvau la relation de confiance
brisé entre civils et forces de l'ordre
le malaise est palpable au sein de
l'exécutif mais partagée entre les
revendications des syndicats policiers
et l'opinion publique emmanuel macron se
positionne en faveur des forces de
l'ordre en mars 2019 au cours d'une
réunion du grand débat national
le président monte au créneau et réfute
le terme de violences policières des
mots inacceptables dans un état de droit
d'après le chef de l'exécutif vous me
parlez de répression je vous dis c'est
faux le jour où vous serez attaqué par
quelqu'un le jour où vous aurez un
assaillant le jour où a terrorist
viendra peut-être que je ne vous
souhaite pas vous appellerez qui vous
n'appellerait pas aujourd'hui ce que
vous êtes en train de défendre vous
verrez un policier ou un gendarme parce
que c'est l'ordre public et il
intervient pour la sécurité de tous et
que des paroles
un an après cette sortie le chef de
l'état revient avec un nouveau credo
prévenir formés et surtout sanctionnez
des sanctions qui peine visiblement à
être appliquée à l'image de la sphère
cédric joue via ce chauffeur-livreur
décédée après un contrôle par trois
policiers toujours en poste à l'heure
actuelle
c'est donc l'une des affaires
emblématiques des violences policières
en france des ferchaux via dans qu'en
pensent les français ce soir notre
reporter nadège abderrazak est allé à la
rencontre de christian show via le père
de cédric il souhaite que justice soit
rendue après la mort de son fils suite à
un contrôle de police c'était le 3
janvier 2020 reportage
nous sommes à présent dans un lieu un
peu particulier pour la famille shaw via
christian vous nous raconter un peu
pourquoi ou est-ce qu'on est précisément
dans l'entrepôt de la société où cédric
travaillait en tant que responsable
coursier et s'occuper des skis étaient
deux roues et des hommes de l'entretien
des véhicules et puis de la fonction de
responsable
coursier
christian là on est à la place qu aurait
dû avoir cédric il ya même son nom je
vois sur l'ordinateur seul ordinateur de
cédric ben k suivez le changement de
poste puisqu'on a déménagé depuis et son
fils a pris le relais
aujourd'hui
c'était la passe de cédric c'est là
qu'il aurait dû
commencer sa journée le matin alors on
parle beaucoup à des circonstances de la
mort de cédric mais quel fils c'était
quel père de famille s'était cédric
étant un vrai repère aussi aussi de vous
si bien dans sa vie professionnelle que
surtout dans sa vie familiale voilà
cédric souriant toujours le sourire avec
ça quand il avec ses enfants et sur rien
donc c'est il était très famille c'était
très important pour les bambins c'était
c'était le pilier de la famille qui est
important c'est ce et ses enfants avant
tout est ce que ça vous fait de revoir
ces photos
ça vous fait du bien et du mal
si je peux dire ça fait du bien et du
mal parce que et et qui soutient la
belle sofia avec les deux hommes de sa
vie sophie avec son papier et sur pattes
sofia c'est la grande la grande figure
en se fiant à grande
christian les condamnations de policiers
sont rares mais elles existent
vous avez commencé un long combat avec
votre famille pour obtenir justice pour
votre fils est ce que vous pensez
pouvoir à un jour l'obtenir oui parce
que aujourd'hui j'ai confiance en la
justice la justice m'a prouvé que elle
défend bien le dossier à cherche la
vérité donc la vérité
nous au vu des images on a confiance
donc pour moi aujourd'hui c'est un
assassinat c'est un meurtre c'est tout
ce que vous voulez mais là il n'y a pas
d' excuses
nous sommes précisément à l'angle de la
rue de suffren et du quai branly à
quelques pas de la tour eiffel
d'ailleurs que vous voyez derrière nous
dites moi qu'est ce que ça vous fait de
revenir un an et huit mois après que la
vie de votre fils a tourné au drame que
la vôtre et celle de votre famille et
bien a pris une tournure cauchemardesque
oui quand je leur baisse parce que les
cinq enfants
aujourd'hui n'accepte toujours pas la
disparition de leur père surtout dans
les circonstances c'est pas une maladie
c'est par moeurs et il avait rien
demandé un autre citoyen travailleur
le galanga qui part faire sa tournée le
matin et puis sa vie s'arrête là la vie
d'une famille entière s'est arrêtée le 3
janvier 2020 moi je suis toujours bloqué
au 3 janvier 2020
il voit là c'est ici que ça s'est passé
c'est ici qu'il est tombé sur un
assassin a
pour moi michael perez est le plus grand
meurtrier qui puisse exister dans la
tête il a tué mon fils lui c'est celui
qui a réalisé la clé d'étranglement sur
votre fils lors de l'interpellation et
l'attrapé par derrière il ya fait la clé
d'étranglement et il s'est jamais arrêté
j'ai arrêté quand cédric était mort il
n'avait aucune chance de s'en sortir
même en leur disant cette fois j'étouffe
il a pas eu de on ne s'est pas apitoyé
du sort de cédric c'est une formation
qui doit être revue voilà c'est tout
d'une formation qui doit être vu on doit
on doit arrêter la clé d'étranglement on
doit arrêter le placage van tran vous
mettez un mec au sol avec trois costauds
dessus avec les genoux sur le mais même
le placage ventrale ccc voué à la mort
et lui il a eu le double et le coup
double et vos avocats ont écrit un
courrier au ministère de l'intérieur en
décembre 2020 pour demander la
suspension à des fonctionnaires de
police mis en cause dans la mort de
votre fils vous avez reçu
courant juin je crois courant juin
dernier une
revue catégorique de la part de de
gérald darmanin donc une fin de
non-recevoir à votre demande les
fonctionnaires de police
ont été mises en examen mais ne sont pas
suspendus j'imagine que c'est quelque
chose qui est tout de même difficile à
digérer bah oui parce que vous dites en
fin de compte vous avez quatre
meurtriers qui se baladent ont ils ont
tué quelqu'un et aujourd'hui on
maintenant ils vont travailler lambda
tous les matins la ville lors vie n'a
pas changé donc tout ça c'est encore une
supercherie de gérald darmanin comme il
sait faire voilà ne veut pas reconnaître
quand il a des fruits pourris parce que
pour lui la police a tous les droits
monsieur gérald darmanin monsieur macron
c'est qu'un tissu de mensonges vous à
vous implorer des choses que vous ne
respectez pas puisque vous cautionnez
tout ça aujourd'hui cautionne puisqu'il
du fait qu'il veut pas mettre les quatre
individus à pied donc ils cautionnent ça
et avant de débattre avec un os nos
invités politiques qui vont
être sur ce plateau dans quelques
instants nous retrouvons nadège
abderrazak pour aller plus loin bonsoir
nadège vous avez suivi on s'en souvient
en tant que reporter d'arreter france
toutes ces manifestations le samedi
régulièrement de gilet jaune c'était
parfois extrêmement entendu violent
est-ce qu'on retrouve le même la même
atmosphère lors des manifestations anti
passe sanitaire désormais
alors absolument pas absolument pas les
dispositifs de police sont tout aussi
importants lors de ces manifestations
anti pas sanitaire mais on n'a pas
assisté de à des violences particulières
des vagues des violences similaires ce
qu'on a pu voir lors des manifestations
de gilet jaune alors pour ça il ya
plusieurs raisons d'abord à des
manifestations anti passe sanitaires y
en a un peu partout dans le monde il y
en a royaume uni en allemagne en grèce
en israël et ça se passe relativement
bien là bas donc ça ferait quand même un
petit peu tâche pour le gouvernement
français que ces manifestations anti pas
sanitaire dégénère en france faut aussi
penser que dans huit mois il ya une
échéance assez importante pour emmanuel
macron il a joué sa réélection cette
élection présidentielle elle a lieu dans
huit mois emmanuel macron on imagine
qu'il ne veut pas qu'on se souvienne de
ces derniers mois de son mandat
présidentiel comme des mois de violences
comme des mois d'affrontements entre les
forces de l'ordre aient une partie et
certains manifestants est très
certainement pas revoir revivre les
scènes de chaos qu'on a pu voir lors des
manifestations de gilet jaune 901 2018
début 2019 alors cette atmosphère est là
elle a complètement changé parce que ça
fait 18 mois maintenant que les français
sont soumis à des restrictions
sanitaires de plus en plus importante et
finalement le fait de manifester c'est
un petit peu tout ce qu'il leur reste
donc voilà cette atmosphère à la changer
sur le terrain on assiste de plus en
plus à des discussions maintenant entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre on a
les manifestants qui se rapproche des
forces de l'ordre qui leur est bien
qu'il leur demande à eux aussi comment
ce qu'ils pensent de la situation
actuelle des manifestants qui demandent
aussi aux forces de l'ordre de les
rejoindre dans leur dans leur mouvement
alors que lors des manifestations de
gilet jaune on voyait des policiers des
forces de l'ordre est très fermé assez
hostile et dès qu'un manifestant
s'approchaient et bien finalement il
dégainait tout de suite la matraque ou
le ou la grenade de gaz lacrymogènes
pourquoi ça se passe bien plus ou moins
bien encore mieux en tout cas que lors
des manifestations de gilet jaune à ces
manifestations anti pas sanitaire c'est
aussi parce qu'on n'a pas vu d'éléments
radicaux d'éléments violents infiltrés
ces manifestations contrôle pas
sanitaire donc ça joue aussi c'était le
cas lors des manifestations de gilet
jaune et ce n'est pas le cas en tout cas
pas pour l'instant lors de ces
manifestations contrôle pas sanitaires
merci nadège ad razak est tout de suite
place à notre débat politique la
sécurité 1 de manière plus globale 1 va
être l'un des enjeux de cette
présidentielle pour sept français sur
dix selon un sondage ifop ce sera un
thème majeur de la campagne dans le
domaine sécuritaire emmanuel macron at
il été à la hauteur at il tenu ses
promesses c'est l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
et avec nous sur ce plateau françois
pupponi député modem du val d'oise
ancien maire de sarcelles françois
pupponi bonsoir vous a laissé un très
bien vous voulez les problématiques nous
allons aborder dans quelques instants à
vos côtés également david guiraud porte
parole de la france insoumise bonsoir
david guiraud merci d'être avec nous
emmanuel macron qui va évidemment
défendre son bilan sécuritaire dans
quelques semaines en vue de l'élection
présidentielle ça d'ailleurs un petit
peu déjà commencé à marseille hier vous
le le député dont le mouvement au fait
alliance avec eux avec la majorité vous
êtes satisfait du bilan sécuritaire des
manuels macron dos c'est un peu un point
de faiblesse il le sait d'ailleurs les
de la dia il l'a dit à marseille
puisqu'il année des moyens
supplémentaires pour bien constater
qu'effectivement jusqu'à présent le
compte n'y était pas lorsqu il rajoute
300 policiers à marseille c'est parce
qu'il a manqué trois cents il le fait en
fin de mandature donc effectivement
emmanuel macron est tout à fait
conscient que dans ce domaine là il a
peut-être un point de faiblesse et qu'il
va essayer de rattraper dans l'ads dans
les mois qui viennent le sujet de la
sécurité qui a longtemps été oubliée
revient mais parce qu'en fait les
français eux ils sont confrontés revient
sur le devant de la scène parce que la
réalité rattrape eux maintenant les
choses avant de vous interroger david
biraud un jour et vous faire écouter
l'avis de michel barnier à regarder ce
que dit l'ancien négociateur en chef de
l'union européenne qui désormais donc
candidat lui aussi à peut-être une
arrière pensée à la primaire de la
droite pour la présidentielle
le pouvoir actuel n'a pas pris la mesure
de la sécurité dans le pays pour moi
c'est le principal échec de ce
quinquennat
david biraud le principal échec de
kannad emmanuel macron la sécurité bas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il est venu
parler de trafic de drogue et en termes
de lutte contre le trafic de drogue le
compte y est pas parce qu à chaque fois
on fait la même chose on arrive alors
les dirigeants arrivent ils posent leurs
grosses valises indie on va faire plus
de policiers partout on va donner plus
d'argent à la police alors il faut
mettre tous la même chose parce que pour
l'instant emmanuel macron a pas ramené
deux policiers un pensionnat ramené du
mauvais temps ça c'est sûr maintenant
sur les policiers a eu des cars de crs
pour vider les avenues ça on le sait
mais il en train de nous faire des
promesses des promesses qui n'ont
probablement
pas été concrétisées avant la fin de la
campagne présidentielle et des promesses
je le rappelle parce qu'on a tendance à
l'oublier qu'ont déjà été fait par
gérald darmanin il ya quelques mois
parce que gérald darmanin en juillet
disait déjà qu'il y aurait des policiers
en plus donc là on est dans le cadre
d'une campagne présidentielle bon très
bien ayons un débat dans le cadre de la
campagne présidentielle mais aujourd'hui
c'est quoi on a un trafic de drogue qui
s'étend dans le pays on a de la
consommation qui s'étend et les
répliques les réponses uniquement
sécuritaire de tous considérés sous
l'angle de la police et que la police
doit régler tous les problèmes présents
dans les quartiers bas ce n'est pas la
bonne réponse voilà on a déposé enfin en
tout cas notre député eric coquerel a
déposé par exemple une proposition de
loi sur la légalisation du cannabis pour
changer de braquet en matière de
sécurité mais pas que il ya aussi la
question de la prévention pourquoi ya de
plus en plus de jeunes par exemple qui
se mettent à consommer du cannabis de
plus en plus tôt aussi parce que
notamment dans les quartiers mais aussi
dans les autres endroits en france eh
ben on n'a pas d'être de social on n'a
pas d'aidé psychosociale parce qu'on
refuse de traiter la question du
cannabis par exemple autrement par le
biais sécuritaire et donc on refuse de
dire que c'est par exemple un problème
de santé publique et que des fois c'est
pas le ministère de l'intérieur qui doit
tout gérer mais aussi le ministère de la
santé le ministère de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance bref tout c'est tout ce genre
de politique un peu transversale qui
fait qu'on s'en sortirait plutôt que
d'être là embourbé dans des réponses qui
depuis 30 ans j'entends le même discours
et qui change rien à la réalité des gens
françois pupponi cet accord avec ses
talents la politique en matière de lutte
contre les stupéfiants et les doubles et
moi la fraîcheur de ses recettes à 20
ans déjà entendu qu'il ya des structures
sanitaires sociales qui prennent en
charge les toxicomanes qui sont des
personnes qui sont malades qu'il faut
aider il faut accompagner des structures
elles sont là elles existent
toutes les mesures que l'on peut prendre
en compte elle présente après il faut
que la personne ait envie de se soigner
aussi parce que on ne peut pas l'obliger
assure des soins il faut qu'ils
acceptent de rentrer d'un processus mais
globalement ça ça existe après ce que
l'on constate c'est qu'il ya de plus en
plus de jeunes qui bascule d'un trafic
de drogue manipulés par des réseaux
extrêmement bien organisé et que ces
réseaux savent très bien et comprenant
des très jeunes dans les quartiers dès
lors qu'ils sont mineurs ils ne risquent
plus rien donc bien entendu qu'il faut
une réponse police justice pour faire
tomber ces réseaux il faut aussi des
relations internationales avec les pays
qui importent
c'est très bien pendant que 70% de
cannabis qui est importé vient du maroc
donc on sait très bien qu'il ya aussi
des relations intérêts sur les mettre en
place et il faut effectivement aider les
toxicomanes à sortir de cette addiction
parce que c'était un vrai fléau ça c'est
ce qui met en place dans beaucoup de
quartiers y compris en seine-saint-denis
par tous depuis depuis des années
maintenant ça nécessite des moyens sa
descente des moyens humains mais si on
ne lutte pas contre les trafics drogue
beau jeu je connais bien marseille
j'étais le président de l'anru quand
j'allais la castellane pour
essayer de rénover le quartier fallait
que je demande l'autorisation aux
dealers pour entrer dans le quartier
voilà donc ça c'est pas admissible dans
un pays comme le nôtre c'est pas les
dealers qui doivent faire la loi david
guiraud pour revenir effectivement
dès razak notamment sur les violences
policières selon vous elles ont
également alors violences policières
présumées pour certains parce que
certains vous diront que voilà que c'est
dans les deux sens sa marque est
clairement le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macro et donner une impression justement
de nom sécurité dans le pays aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'en fait on est on est
gouverné par un président
qu'ils nous parlent tout le temps de
sécurité etc oublie que dans les textes
fondamentaux de notre république c'est
pas la sécurité qui est la valeur mise
en avant c'est la sûreté la sûreté c'est
le fait d'être protégé contre les
agressions des autres mais aussi contre
les agressions de l'état et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a oublié pendant le
quinquennat c'est que en vérité quand on
manifeste aujourd'hui on n'est pas en
sécurité quand on défend ses droits on
n'est pas en sécurité quand on fait des
actions parfois même des actions de
jeunes comme le font les jeunes à
l'université ou engagés dans les
mouvements écologistes et ben ces jeunes
là ils sont pas en sécurité moi je me
souviens que les premières images du
quinquennat macron c'est quoi ces
lycéens de mantes la jolie par exemple
qui sont genoux les mains derrière la
tête ce n'est pas une manière de traiter
notre jeunesse n'est pas une manière de
traiter les manifestants moi je moi j'ai
pas de tabou sur la question de la
sécurité jeudi jusqu à force de tout
regarder sous l'angle uniquement de la
sécurité en pensant que la police va
tout résoudre d'une on va mettre les
policiers dans une difficulté énorme
parce que bon il ya la question des
moyens mais il ya aussi la question des
missions c'est si on pense qu'ils vont
résoudre tous les problèmes de la
société eh bien ils vont se prendre tous
les problèmes de la société en pleine
tête et ça c'est pas possible et
derrière effectivement il ya la question
des moyens mais moi je continuerai à le
dire quand vous avez 33 % des jeunes
dans des quartiers populaires qui sont
au chômage en comparaison dans les
autres endroits d'une ville c'est
environ 15 % 15 % c'est énorme pour les
15-29 ans c'est énorme mais quand vous
en avez 33 % c'est-à-dire un tiers que
ces jeunes là ils voient leurs parents
partir charbonné toute la journée à
faire trois lignes de bus parce qu'à
marseille les cales et les quartiers
nord de l'enclavé donc la maman elle
doit faire les trois lignes de bus qui
revient crever pour art fait du ménage
pour être payé aussi mal ben il ya un
moment faut aussi se dire mais pourquoi
est ce que notre pays n'est pas capable
de convaincre des jeunes de dettes dans
un autre modèle d'être dans une autre
forme d'organisation que celle du trafic
de drogue et c'est ça la question et je
laisserai pas dire parce que moi pour
moi je le constate ça n'est pas vrai
qu'il n'ya pas de risque à être dealer
ou guetteurs on peut partir en prison à
l'âge de 13 ans france il ya des
règlements de compte des tabassages et
parfois même c'est le cas à marseille
notamment des meurtres des assassinats
donc c'est pas vrai que c'est sans
risque et c'est quand on fait du trafic
de drogue et qu'on y reste allez je
dirais 10 ans 15 ans parce qu'à un
moment les gamins ils veulent s'en aller
parce que on tient pas une famille avec
le trafic de drogue ont fait pas une vie
normale et ben qu'est ce qui se passe
par les jeunes il se retrouve sans
formation sans qualification sans avoir
cotisé pour leur retraite pour leur
assurance sociale et il se retrouva du
coup dans des métiers extrêmement
précaires ou dans rien du tout à la rue
et là on a des gens qui vrille donc
voilà c'est là qu'il faut s'attaquer à
ces problèmes la légaliser le cannabis
comme le propose par exemple la france a
soumis ce n'est pas la seule solution
mais par contre ça veut dire qu'on
change de braquet on arrête la politique
sécuritaire on a fait que ça depuis 30
ans depuis 30 ans la consommation en
cannabis en france elle a triplé de
volume book c'est pas vrai que ça marche
des réponses sécuritaires alors je
t'aurais oui françois pour venir avant
de vous donner évidemment l'apparence
vous réponds qu'on fasse un petit retour
en arrière en quelques instants
justement sur les promesses du candidat
macron en 2017 en la matière il y en
avait quelques unes justement en matière
de sécurité déjà pas forcément obtenu
d'ailleurs le recrutement d'effectifs
regardez un cette infographie selon le
figaro avant l'été un peu plus de 6000
policiers et gendarmes seulement avaient
été embauchés donc clairement on est on
est pas dans les clous au niveau de la
promesse de campagne qu'est ce qui a
péché françois pupponi selon vous
la rupture c'était le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy où il supprime 12000
postes
est remonté au niveau de long était ça
veut dire à moi et manuel valls l'a fait
lors parmi les premiers à dire qu'on va
embaucher mais entre loin on dira va
embaucher le mot on va les former et une
polémique sur le fait qu'on ait pourrait
faire en sorte qu'ils aient du bleu à b
ou présents dans les territoires et que
les français voient un peu plus de
policiers on a réduit la durée de
formation et on sait très bien qu'en
réduisant la durée de formation on est
ensuite des jeunes policiers qui sont
pas forcément bien formés dans des
situations qui sont vraiment compliqué
parce que on a des statuts de la
fonction publique et on peut le
comprendre c'est normal les policiers
des plus expérimentés ils ont pas envie
de rester dans les quartiers des plus
difficiles donc ils demandent leur
mutation pour les endroits qui sont
moins difficiles et ils sont remplacés
par des jeunes qui sortent de l'école de
l'école de police et qu'on met dans les
quartiers sans la formation nécessaire
avec un encadrement qui est défaillant
ça peut pas fonctionner on sait très
bien qu'il faut réformer le statut de la
police on peut recruter ça se fait
globalement on revient à un niveau d
mais ce qui nous manque c'est de garder
des policiers expérimentés dans les
territoires comme ont le plus besoin et
puis après il faut aussi de
l'investigation il faut ce qu'on appelle
du bleu sur des policiers présents dans
la rue qui foulent rails et puis il faut
des services de renseignements des
services d'investigation et sur les
services de renseignement on a beaucoup
lutter contre les réseaux terroristes et
on a un peu laissé d'autres services
d'investigation qui aurait été
nécessaire donc bien entendu on manque
de policiers bien entendu cours du
procès mais ce qui est terrible c'est
qu'on doit attendre quatre ans pour
faire ce constat pas je les entends
parler de recruter mais ça oui ça fait
dix ans par exemple qu'on parle du fait
et d'ailleurs vous avez un rapport
parlementaire sénatoriale qui a été fait
par le je crois un communiste est quelqu
un de leurs ailes et l'air c'était le
rapport qu cuando cornut gentille sur la
seine saint denis où l'on vous explique
qu'il vous dise effectivement je suis
d'accord avec vous sur le constat mais
ça fait des années qu'il ya des gens qui
disent par exemple on manque d'officiers
de police judiciaire parce que faut
arrêter de considérer que c'est les
interpellations comme ça dans la rue de
la bac qui vont démanteler des réseaux
de drogue ça n'est pas vrai j'ai fait il
ya deux fois moins d'eau pj a conseillé
catherine ce qui a été fait c'est de
dire après ces constats et ça ça a été
fait si le dire voilà quand vous êtes
policiers en seine-saint-denis vous êtes
mieux payé qu'ailleurs on vous donne des
moyens supplémentaires parce que mais le
boulot c'est pas le même ça ça existe et
l'on prône essayer de fidéliser les
poésies sur terra avec de l'attrait
parce que les policiers disent las des
mois jugent par ailleurs puisque je suis
payé la même chose ailleurs oussama
difficile donc là aujourd'hui c'est fait
donc il ya des efforts qui sont faits on
ne peut pas dire que rien n'était fait
maintenant entre le moment où on décide
une politique osant va recruter et mon
recrute ses des années un policier il
faut le temps de le former mais il ya
quand même autre chose c'est que par
exemple on a supprimé la police de
proximité et résultat on se retrouve
avec des unités policières qui
connaissent très mal leurs terrains ou
moins bien qui débarque dans les
quartiers parce que c'est pas vrai qu'il
n'ya pas de quartier on peut pas entrer
mais qui débarque donc les conflits
c'est direct c'est la première relation
que que les policiers avec les jeunes
c'est des conflits d'un côté ou d'autres
mots le but ce n'est pas de créer un
camp contre l'autre mais c'est comme ça
que ça se crée on a on a détruit la
police de proximité on veut pas refaire
de la police de proximité je me souviens
d'un harman qui nous disent justement la
police de proximité c'était en quelque
sorte la bac ça n'est pas vrai donc il
faut se
comprend parce que c'est vrai que ça
revient souvent
c'est ça le nom ça s'appelle revue la
police de reconquête républicaine
moi je dis non je suis désolé enquête
républicaine kay ce contrat d'une offre
vous réponds terme et moi limiter les
policiers les commissaires moi je suis
élu depuis 25 ans dans ces quartiers les
policiers les commissaires on les
connaît on les voit ils sont là la
police avait pas elle n'est pas dans son
bureau elle existe la police de
proximité 2 de fait de fait le problème
ils sont pas s'ils sont pas en nombre
suffisant ils sont pas un nombre
suffisant dimanche un média jours et
puis après il ya un événement
effectivement vous faites quelque chose
qu'on n'a jamais su régler qui me paraît
surréaliste c'est que là pour le coup ça
relève de la direction et dans la police
nationale et personne n'y arrivais c'est
un constat d'échec quand des policiers
de ces commissionnaires demande des
mutations ils partent en mars
ils sont remplacés en septembre sortie
d'école qu'il ya quatre mois dans lequel
il manque 10 15 20 30 policiers dans un
commissariat donc et ça on essaie
d'expliquer aux à la police nationale il
faut changer donc manquer les zones dans
lesquelles les policiers ne vont plus
non
sincèrement ça n'existe pas ah bon selon
les policiers vont partout on l'entend
les policiers ont partout le problème
c'est qu'ils ne vont pas partout tout le
temps donc il a effectivement comme tel
est le cas de marseille fab et moi
j'étais président de l'anru chalet
rénové le café la castellane il fallait
que je demande dealer l'autorisation de
rentrer pour dépenser l'argent public
bon il n'y avait pas de policier bon
mais par contre quand les policiers
s'est dit allez y j allais il faisait le
ménage et il occupait le terrain mais
ils sont pas tous les jours donc le vrai
problème c'est que vous manque de moyens
nous empêche d'être présents 24 heures
sur 24 que des jeunes dans les quartiers
et des checkpoints ou c'est eux qui
décident qui rentre et qui sort c'est
une réalité mais quand la police décide
de dire y'a pas de chaque mode elle y
arrive donc elles rendent partout la
police c'est parfois un peu tendu mais
comme partout par contre elle n'y va pas
tous les jours quand on entend françois
pupponi nous dire voilà il ya des
checkpoints et les jeunes qui décident
et quand on sait que 86% des français
pour eux la sécurité sera l'enjeu de la
présidentielle
à la france insoumise est-ce que vous
vous sentez la main suffisamment fermes
sur ce genre de sujet est-ce que c'est
pas le reproche qu'on va vous faire non
on n'a pas de tabou par contre moi je
vous le dit c'est moi ce qui me ce qui
me saoule c'est qu'on parle que de
sécurité et j'ai quand les gens savent
que je passe par exemple sur un média g1
j'ai des amis on a marseille il dit et
écoute dealer quand même que c'est pas
baltimore quoi voilà ce dont les
quartiers de marseille s'est pas non
plus c'est pas non plus les kalachnikovs
tous les jours et où c'est pas ça la
réalité oui des fois il ya des
checkpoints ça arrive
c'est un endroit europe où il ya le plus
de matches ces cafards ne pas être
sécurité il ya que 24 heures dans une
journée on parle pas des autres
problèmes on parle pas du fait que vous
ayez des gamins qui soit dans des
territoires enclavés cueillez 33 % de
chômage sur ces zones là voire plus sur
les quartiers nord de marseille et que
la seule solidarité aujourd'hui qui
existait entre les habitants on parle
pas que ça on valorise pas ça et on
n'essaye pas de sortir de ça les
policiers ne régleront pas sa poignée de
leur permettre autant vous voulez vous
pouvez supprimer les techniques vous
pouvez mettre des zones et militarisé si
vous voulez la misère extra l'armée le
fait que les gens croient que la
rondelle n'est pas un problème de
marseille qui est unique en france c'est
que les élus de droite comme de gauche
depuis 30 ans ont passé leur temps à se
taper dessus sur traille et cuisine je
prends l'exemple de lyon la métropole de
lyon il ya eu vaulx en velin ya 30 ans
et à un moment les quartiers de vaulx en
velin est d'ailleurs était enclavé on
les élus sont mis d'accord entre les
villes riches des pays pauvres les
villes de droite et villes de gauche
pour dire qu'on va arrêter et on va
désenclaver les quartiers donc parce que
c'est pas la ville qui peut payer le
transport c'est l'internaute et c'est la
région se mettront pas ok très bien yj
son arrivée marseille c'est le seul
endroit où on n'arrive pas ce que les
gens se mettent autour d'une table pour
dire ok les transports c'est la région
va y aller la métropole doit faire son
effort les écoles c'est la ville et on
n'y arrive pas parce que il ya un
microcosme local qui fait que
politiquement on sait les difficultés ce
cas scénarisera trois ans du nom est
pardon c'est ça c'est un peu facile
parce qu'on avait la responsabilité
j'étais président de l'anru c'est là
villes de france où j'ai failli
reprendre 180 millions parce que n'a pas
été dépensée au bout de dix ans ils
avaient dit
les élus de l'état a dit on vous donne
104 millions pour refaire les écoles etc
et au bout de dix ans mais il n'est pas
des poursuites oui mais justement où
allait l'argent total n'était pas
dépenser sur sur marseille merci
messieurs live made avant la fin de
cette rue des problèmes un peu concret
des personnes en situation de handicap
dans les quartiers nord je peux vous
dire qu'ils n'ont pas le revivre en fait
donc ça c'est le genre de choses aussi
con dont on aimerait parler pas de
problème pour pas être sécurité mais si
toute la campagne c'est ça ça reflète
pas non plus le quotidien des gens aimés
que vous exprimer en tout cas merci
david pour durer merci françois pupponi
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et c'est la fin de cette émission
on se retrouve lundi à 20h pour un
prochain numéro l'actualité continue à
22 heures pour un point complet sur la
journée
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous et
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité mais idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des lignes ans aujourd'hui on a
une gauche extrême musées d'alès de
sauter
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
bonjour bienvenue dans la troisième
saison de ses caches ces caches que vous
pouvez regarder encore s'en passe
sanitaires